[Música]
Durante los nueve meses de presencia
rusa en gerson Víctor luchó
clandestinamente contra los ocupantes
en ese entonces dirigía una red de
partisanos hombres y mujeres que
resistían en secreto
[Música]
Aunque operaba sin uniforme y sin gloria
este ejército en las sombras jugó un
papel clave en la liberación de la
ciudad en noviembre pasado los rusos se
han replegado sobre la orilla izquierda
del neeper gersón se extiende sobre la
orilla derecha ahora el río constituye
la línea de frente
los partisanos han vuelto a ser simples
habitantes como Víctor en marzo de 2022
montó una red de cinco personas
encargadas de vigilar las actividades
rusas en el centro de la ciudad
mis compañeros y yo recibimos armas el
primer día de la guerra
eran muchos locales a los que conocía
bien pero ucranianos recolectores de
basura personas del centro de la ciudad
al lado del edificio de ocho plantas
había unos neumáticos todos los días yo
hacía la misma ruta y después me sentaba
en esos neumáticos los chicos de la red
venían a encontrarse conmigo caminaban
por la calle se fijaban en las idas y
venidas en el nuevo material militar que
llegaba me traían sus informaciones y
después yo se las transmitía a los
nuestros en el ejército
me vestía de forma muy sencilla casi
como un indigente teníamos que fingir
que éramos indigentes O algo parecido
para darle impresión de que estábamos en
la calle sin hacer nada de que éramos
personas sin ningún interés
debíamos Mostrar que no teníamos ningún
tipo de importancia que no jugábamos
ningún papel que no podíamos ser
partidarios solo simples habitantes así
era
a través de uno de sus parientes que se
quedó en la zona libre Víctor le
transmitía informaciones a un agente de
la inteligencia ucraniana
su familia no estaba al tanto de sus
actividades
una sola y única vez unos días antes de
La retirada de los rusos acompañó a su
hijo que quería descolgar una bandera
rusa de un edificio administrativo
estaba colgado tuve que saltar varias
veces para agarrar no era de buena
calidad se rompió rápido
dice lo mismo del otro lado
Afortunadamente no lo grabamos hoy ha
sido severamente castigada
[Música]
aunque los rusos se han ido de la ciudad
sus proyectiles y cohetes siguen cayendo
constantemente sobre jerson
esta mañana el objetivo fue un grupo de
bomberos que estaban en su estación un
informante reportó a los rusos la
congregación
todavía quedan muchos colaboradores en
la ciudad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace 45 años olena y Valentín se
conocieron a las orillas del
[Música]
nieper construyeron su vida al borde del
río después de haber pasado una vida
entera pescando entre las Islas
Valentín conoce todas sus corrientes y
canales aquí se solía vivir en barcos
pero actualmente las Riberas del nieper
son el lugar más expuesto de
Esta es una zona gris donde están a la
vez nuestros soldados y los rusos
vienen aquí con barcos como este
instalan el mortero disparan cuatro o
cinco veces y se van
aquí había un pequeño puente
donde estaban atados en nuestros tres
barcos
y cayó un misil justo en medio
esto es todo lo que queda
durante toda la ocupación Valentín el
pescador jubilado también fue mitrich el
jefe de una célula clandestina de
resistencia
desde el principio acordamos tener dos
seudónimos uno normal y otro que sólo
debía usarse en caso de emergencia
y el de emergencia era bitter
si pasaba la información y el mensaje
decía Peter pide que hagan esto o
aquello era una señal para los demás
significaba que me habían capturado Eso
era lo más importante para proteger la
red
nuestra misionera vigilar el nieper y el
río naftaban ver si los rusos traían
combustible o no Qué embarcaciones
pasaban en qué dirección iban Nos daba
miedo que las embarcaciones de la flota
rusa vinieran Aquí
también había algunas misiones por
ejemplo en la línea del tren hubo que
hacer estallar el transformador
en nuestro grupo había cuatro personas y
yo sabía poco sobre sus redes cada uno
tenía sus propios agentes
[Música]
movía un acuerdo entre menos cepas mejor
podrás dormir en la noche porque cada
palabra de más era peligrosa
no todo el mundo soportaría la tortura
con electrochoques
a mi nieto lo torturaron durante dos
días aguantó cuando volvió brillaba como
una bombilla
las misiones eran cada vez más
peligrosas los rusos multiplicaban los
puestos de control
yo transportaba a los fusiles escondidos
en el fondo de las cajas de pescado
guardé las calas
había que llevarlas a oleski y en la
intersección cerca habían instalado el
puesto de control inspeccionaron el auto
y lo único que me salvó fue que el
soldado no quiso meter la mano más en el
fondo en las cajas de pescado para
verificar
cuando me fui de ahí
tenía todo el pantalón mojado
[Música]
del otro lado del Río en los territorios
ocupados las redes de partisanos como la
de Valentín aún siguen activas sus
informaciones son indispensables para
las unidades del ejército ucraniano
[Música]
hoy estoy observa con ayuda de un dron
las posiciones enemigas desde la Ribera
controlada por los ucranianos
unos rusos viven en esa casa
ahí tienen su puesto de comandos son
entre cinco y siete
esa es su posición
El joven soldado de 23 años graduado De
filosofía pertenece al Batallón
esta unidad ucraniana realiza
operaciones especiales detrás de las
líneas enemigas en el territorio
controlado por los rusos
esa es su posición pero nunca salen
porque saben que los vemos
A veces nuestros muchachos van a esa
isla de noche para observar más de cerca
sus posiciones
un soldado trata de Instalar una antena
para establecer una conexión antes de la
misión la unidad Lleva más de una semana
observando el lugar detectando cada
detalle cada movimiento del enemigo
los soldados recibieron una misión
dentro de unos días deberán atacar ese
puesto de comando ruso durante la noche
el plan de la operación parece
arriesgado sus camaradas tendrán que
cruzar el río en barco y atracar en la
Ribera enemiga para tomar por asalto la
posición rusa
vitalie es el encargado de la
inteligencia en la unidad
las operaciones especiales llevadas a
cabo por estos hombres También tienen el
objetivo de sembrar la duda entre las
filas de las fuerzas rusas cuando un
grupo de sabotajes se infiltra en una
parte de la línea de frente se activa
una alerta en una zona extremadamente
grande
hay que cambiar las contraseñas aumentar
los controles es muy estresante muy
estresante y desmoralizante
[Música]
puedo decir que la destrucción de los
edificios los asesinatos o hasta la
captura de una persona incluso de un
oficial del ejército enemigo tiene menos
impacto que ese estado de alerta
cuando el enemigo sabe que un grupo de
Sabotaje como el nuestro se ha
infiltrado y que es peligroso estar ahí
donde están que toda su línea de frente
está en estado de alerta máximo que
están obligados a difundir ampliamente
esta información se instala el temor el
peligro
eso es lo que queremos seguir haciendo
para infiltrarse en territorio enemigo
la unidad suele contar con las
informaciones de las células de
resistencia locales
varias veces me pasó que estaba
trabajando en algunos sitios haciendo el
reconocimiento con el dron y después de
eso recibía informaciones de parte de
ellos
una presencia de equipamiento militar
soldados enemigos posiciones
fortificadas que nunca habría visto sin
su ayuda
y Porque nuestro enemigo se vuelve más
inteligente se camufla con más eficacia
para mí y para mis colegas la ayuda de
Los partidarios no solo es necesaria es
invaluable
el riesgo que estas personas corren Es
mayor que el nuestro el de los soldados
de hecho es mucho mayor porque nosotros
estamos en nuestro territorio
siempre podemos escondernos en alguna
parte
ponernos a salvo y ese no es su caso a
menudo no tiene ninguna ayuda
en gerson unos granjeros nos ayudaron
con informaciones sobre los movimientos
en los campos sobre lo que había en los
hangares ese tipo de cosas
y ya supuesto admiro su valentía y les
tengo el mayor de los respetos
[Música]
muy
caímos en una trampa nos saltaron encima
desde esos canales de allá y desde ese
gruñe y Eran cuatro estaban armados
empezaron a requisar el auto buscaban
armas y municiones
vecinas de gerson y Nicolás
[Música]
alcalde de un grupo de pueblos y jefe de
una célula de resistencia o le era
buscado por las fuerzas rusas en marzo
de 2022 lo detuvieron
[Música]
los rusos me habían identificado como
representante electo local revisaron mi
teléfono y lograron recuperar las fotos
borradas de columnas militares rusas
destruidas y de las coordenadas escritas
de esas informaciones se dieron cuenta
que desde ese teléfono se habían enviado
las coordenadas a la artillería
ucraniana
olé Fue encarcelado en un recinto del
aeropuerto de gersón
ellos sabían que yo conocía los
movimientos de las columnas de blindados
querían saber la identidad de mi fuente
y lo que hacían después con esa
información
al principio mantenían a los prisioneros
en el sótano pero cuando ya no quedó
espacio en los sótanos cavaron huecos y
metieron a la gente dentro
[Música]
hacía frío
digamos que fue una época difícil nos
torturaban no nos daban comida nos
interrogaban
éramos interrogados por diferentes
estructuras los paracaidistas
la policía militar y el fsb
[Música]
sus interrogatorios eran sobre la
organización de resistencia frente a la
ocupación rusa
o le aguantó la tortura en la red se
habían tomado precauciones previas
Tomás teníamos una cadena en Telegram
todos nuestros perfiles estaban
codificados si alguien desaparecía de
los radares lo eliminábamos de esa
cadena inmediatamente cada miembro del
grupo debía cambiar de lugar para pasar
la noche los demás no conocían ese lugar
eso se acordaba desde el principio
también habíamos designado a mi sucesor
Para coordinar nuestras acciones en caso
de que a mí como jefe de grupo me
mataran o me detuvieran lo bueno es que
ningún otro de nuestros partidarios fue
detenido el combatiente de la
resistencia fue transferido a otra
prisión dos meses después lo liberaron
mediante un intercambio de prisioneros
los pueblos que ole administra
estuvieron durante mucho tiempo en plena
línea de frente desde que los rusos se
retiraron de la región la zona ya no
está bombardeada pero todo está
destruido
hoy es Nochebuena o le celebra con
miembros de su antigua red Todavía viven
bajo tierra en un búnker sin agua
corriente
[Música]
sus casas Fueron alcanzadas por cohetes
y ya no pueden ser habitadas
[Música]
fue una de las primeras integrantes de
la resistencia que ole reclutó
mi esposo
yo también tenía que hacer algo tenía
que defender a Ucrania
conocí
le pregunté cómo podía ayudar
a unas personas del pueblo hablamos
sobre lo que se podía hacer y después
nos dieron luz verde para empezar a
patrullar
con ayuda de sus hijos en directo sus
primeras informaciones sobre los
movimientos rusos hablando por teléfono
con el ejército ucraniano
los tanques pasaban por aquí corrimos
por los jardines
[Música]
después nos escondimos entre la hierba
los detectamos con los binoculares
y enviamos una captura de pantalla con
su ubicación
después me llamaron diciendo salgan de
ahí vamos a disparar Entonces nos fuimos
corriendo al pueblo
los soldados nos llamaron de nuevo y
después una vez más para verificar
dimos tres veces el camino de ida y
vuelta con el tiempo el ejército
ucraniano Consideró que svetlana era una
fuente confiable sus informaciones eran
usadas prácticamente al instante
había una fábrica en kisselizca nuestras
fuerzas la bombardeaban constantemente
porque dentro había militares rusos
después de eso nadie creía que todavía
pudiera haber hombres o municiones
porque la fábrica estaba en ruinas pero
yo sabía que quedaba algo lo hablamos me
pasé la información a mis interlocutores
al día siguiente me llamaron y me
dijeron gracias tuvimos un espectáculo
pirotécnico extraordinario
[Música]
la orden llegó hace rato la operación
del Batallón detrás de las líneas
enemigas se llevará a cabo esta noche
[Música]
el equipo de asalto se prepara para
subirse a los barcos y cruzar hasta el
lado ruso el grupo de esto quedará cerca
en la Ribera controlada por los
ucranianos
[Música]
son las 4 de la mañana
orientarán al grupo de asalto desde esta
posición
un soldado arma uno de los drones con
una granada
la artillería ucraniana guiada por el
grupo apunta a la orilla enemiga para
preparar el asalto
a bordo de cuatro barcos los soldados de
la unidad se acercan a la Ribera
controlada por las fuerzas rusas
un soldado salta sobre una mina al
bajarse del barco muere en el acto la
unidad debe continuar tienen 7 minutos
para destruir el puesto de comando ruso
[Aplausos]
los hombres se quedaron más tiempo de lo
previsto 13 minutos en territorio
enemigo de benibacuar bajo el fuego de
las fuerzas rusas
[Música]
los barcos que lograron irse son
atacados con cohetes y granadas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se unía un barco de evacuación para
rescatar a los equipos
en la Ribera opuesta los rusos
localizaron la posición de Vital y
histórico
los hombres se protegen de la artillería
rusa en un búnker
desde su Refugio tratan de saber si
todos los barcos llegaron al lado
ucraniano
[Música]
la artillería no destruyó correctamente
las fortificaciones Como debería haberlo
hecho sabemos que es difícil hacemos lo
que podemos
vaya
un soldado murió y otros tres quedaron
gravemente heridos uno está en coma
recibió un disparo en la cabeza otros
dos fueron alcanzados por las metrallas
de las minas flotantes que había en el
río
sin embargo la operación es considerada
un éxito el puesto de comando fue
destruido y ahora los rusos saben que
incluso detrás del río son vulnerables
[Música]
que es música antes traen el chaleco
antibalas de un compañero herido estaban
juntos en el primer barco
[Música]
fue la operación más difícil que he
hecho en mi vida
ya nada más
no puedo decir que tuviera miedo por mí
Tenía miedo por los muchachos
[Música]
tenía miedo de mirar a los ojos de los
chicos con los que vivo y eso sobre todo
mi amigo cuando se giró para verme todo
ensangrentado y no podía ayudarlo
sabía que si dejaba de disparar eso
podría costarnos la vida a todos
la vida de los demás él pedía ayuda y yo
no podía hacer nada más que hablarle
fue mi primera vez en un barco ellos ya
lo habían hecho a mí me da igual caminar
remar o conducir Lo principal es matar a
esos cabrones Eso es todo
Yo igual antes de la guerra nunca me
había subido en un barco que
había estado en un pequeño catamarán en
el hidroparque de kiev pero nada más
todo lo aprendimos aquí desde finales
del verano
antes de la guerra antes de la invasión
yo era un civil como los demás nunca
había tomado un arma ni matado a nadie
ya
te dije
yo toco el violín cuando empezó la
invasión estaba en mi primer año en la
academia de música de
pero no tenemos opción nuestra
motivación es tratar de que el enemigo
se vaya lo más rápido posible mis dos
hijos y mi mujer están en casa son
hermosos no quiero que sufran ni mi
mujer Ni mi madre entonces no tengo
opción
me acuerdo del verano de 2014 cuando se
Albert mis 15 años
le ayudaba a mi padre a reparar carros
que llegaban del extranjero para
enviarlos al donbas
era un niño veía todos esos militares
geniales barbudos viriles
pensaba que era genial y que cuando
fuera mayor Yo también quería ir en una
camioneta a toda velocidad por los
campos para erradicar al enemigo tampoco
y ocho años después me arrepiento de ese
deseo
mi único plan es volver de esta guerra
sano y salvo
[Música]
en las Riberas de gersón en el barrio de
Valentín y Elena le acaban de disparar a
tres soldados rusos miembros de un grupo
de Sabotaje
así dormimos tranquilos
de emergencia
estamos tan amenazados que si los rusos
llegan hasta aquí nos van a cortar en
pedacitos
radios son para mantenernos en contacto
con los soldados porque los rusos
intervinieron los teléfonos de la zona
y este es mi chaleco antibalas y ese
Elena
[Risas]
no te rías olena si te lo pusiste para
dormir cuando estaban bombardeando la
otra noche Este es mi chaleco antibalas
[Música]
los rusos lanzan una Ráfaga de disparos
con morteros sobre el barrio por enésima
vez
aquí no tenemos un refugio subterráneo
cuando Eso pasa rezamos
Y le pedimos a Dios que proteja nuestra
casa esto es una isla excavas un poco y
ya hay agua por debajo
hay un informante en el barrio y hasta
tenemos una idea de quién es Pero bueno
ya saben este país está tomando el
camino de la Unión Europea entonces todo
se debe hacer respetando la ley con
todos los problemas que nos ha causado
ese idiota Yo mismo me cargaría de él
su vecino pasa para saber cómo están
hacía parte de la célula de partisanos
dirigida por Valentín
los habitantes prorusos eran una de las
principales amenazas durante la
ocupación
sí había personas así
Y antes algunos incluso eran buenos
amigos
pero todo el mundo mostró su verdadera
cara
yo trataba de mantener buenas relaciones
con ellos para que no sospecharan y no
me denunciaran
No creo que hayamos hecho cosas heroicas
simplemente Hicimos lo que había que
hacer
cada uno cumplió sus pequeñas misiones y
espero que hayamos podido ayudar un poco
no había otra opción
[Música]
que es un civil y Qué es un militar
cuando la existencia misma de una nación
está en juego
no estos estudiantes que ahora llevan
uniforme Y estos jubilados convertidos
en miembros de un ejército clandestino
decidieron arriesgar sus vidas Unidos
por una misma causa vivir en libertad
dentro de las fronteras de su país
[Música]